YAHAN ZHOU: Welcome to the
Android Emulator Deep Time.
I am Yahan.
And this is Frank.
We are software engineers from
the Android Emulator team.
So back in the days, in 2015,
in the previous Android Dev
Summit, we announced Android
Emulator [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you remember, here is
what it looks like in 2015.
And it is 2018 now, so things
have progressed quite quickly,
fast.
And we've got a newer
emulator with a newer look.
So if you look at
the details, there
are a few differences
you might have noticed.
Firstly, there is
frameless skin support
in the 2018 emulator,
which doesn't
have the window frame for
you and gives you a better UI
experience.
And secondly, you
might have noticed
that in the expanded panel
there is a much longer feature
list, which we have new features
such as screen recording
and virtual scene support,
snapshot, and Google Play
Store.
So I will go over all those
features in this talk one
by one.
From 2015 to 2018 we have
developed quite a lot of stuff
in the Android Emulators.
And we are mainly
focusing on two areas.
One is the performance
improvement of the emulator,
the other is new features.
And we are focusing on improving
your day-to-day developing
experience, as well as CI
server testing use cases.
So first things first.
Let's get into performance.
The first thing we want to
focus on about performance
is Hypervisor support.
So just a little bit of
background about Hypervisors,
if you are running the Android
Emulator, at the lowest level
you have your computer hardware.
On top of this you have
your operating system.
And the highest level there
is the emulated Android OS.
Between the emulated Android
OS and your operating system,
there lies the Hypervisor,
which translates the Android CPU
commands into your
OS CPU commands.
So that's the part that we
do the CPU acceleration.
If you don't have a Hypervisor,
you can still run the emulator,
but everything
will go pretty slow
and the emulator
becomes super sluggish.
So in 2015, here is the list
of the Hypervisors we support.
On Linux we have KVM.
And on Windows and Mac we
support HAXM with Intel CPU.
So unfortunately,
back in those days,
if you are using an AMD
CPU on Windows machine,
we have no support
for this combination,
so we got a lot of
request from AMD users
to add support for them.
So it's 2018 now.
Things progressed pretty fast.
And obviously we have
new Hypervisor support.
So firstly, we support
a newer version
of HAXM, HAXM 7.3.2,
which is stabler
than the previous
version, and it also
gives you better performance.
Then we added Hypervisor
framework support
for Mac users, which
in most situation
is faster than the HAXM on Mac.
And at last, we support
Hypervisor framework,
also known as HyperV on
Windows, which can emulate AMD.
So finally the combination of
AMD and Intel is supported.
And yeah, this also
gives Docker support.
All right, so here is the
Hypervisor performance.
The next thing we
want to go into
will be the ADB performance.
So a little bit background.
If you try to push an app from
your computer onto your device
when you are debugging
or deploying,
you are going to do this
ADB push command, which copy
and transfer the app from
one entry at the other.
So here we are sharing the
chart for ADB push time
on a physical device
on two different Google
apps, the Google Photo app
and Google Santa Tracker app.
And they are both
on physical devices.
And you can see what the first
thing was that if you are using
an USB cable and if you are
pushing the Google Photo app,
it takes you approximately
eight seconds.
If you are using an USB--
an USB 3 cable, things
goes a lot faster
and it takes you
approximately four seconds.
So you can observe
similar phenomenon
when pushing different app,
like the Google Santa Tracker.
USB 3 cable is in general a
lot faster than USB 2 cable,
but those are for
a physical device.
So how about a performance
on the emulator?
So here is a chart.
If you do app push on
emulator, the Google Photo apps
takes approximately 0.5
seconds, which is a lot faster
than USB 2 or USB 3.
And this other chart is
on an Android Oreo device.
And it turns out that the
OS version matters a lot
as well when you are
doing the app push.
So we've got a chart on the
newer Android Pie device.
And if you working
on a physical device,
the ADB push is a lot
faster on either USB 2 or 3.
And emulator still gives
you a very [INAUDIBLE]
and very constant performance.
So in short, if you are doing
the [INAUDIBLE] deployment
onto at the emulator,
you're not going
to have any worries about either
USB cables or Android versions.
We have you covered.
You always get the best
and consistent performance.
All right, the next
topic we are going
to Quick Boot and Snapshots.
So we're going to
be showing demos.
So with that, let's
hand it to Frank.
FRANK YANG: Thank you, Yahan.
So a top concern of
Android Studio users
is the time taken
to deploy their app,
whether it be to a physical
device or emulator.
And previously, people are
used to this workflow where
they're inside Studio and
they want to deploy their app
and they need to wait for the
emulator to boot up again.
So we tried to address
this in 2017 and 2018.
The first way we
tried to address this
is through Snapshots.
We call this Quick Boot.
With Quick Boot the
device state is completely
saved when you take a snapshot.
And when you take a snapshot
when you exit the emulator
and you resume from
that snapshot, when
you start the emulator again.
So in a sense it's kind of
like sleeping and resuming
a real device.
And we've also made improvements
in recent emulator canary
versions to make it
even closer to that.
So the demo I'm going
to show you here is--
I have two AVD setup
in the AVD Manager.
One of them is called API 28.
And we're going to be
using Quick Boot with that.
And the second one is
called API 28 cold boot.
And we're going
to cold boot that.
And so for the benefit of people
who haven't seen this already,
I'm going to cold boot
one of these AVDs.
You'll see that it starts
out with a black screen,
takes a while to
show the Google logo.
But with Quick Boot the emulator
just pops up right here.
You'll notice that Logcat
has already started up.
And we can interact
with it immediately,
just as the cold boot
emulator has just started up.
All right, so we're
just going to get rid
of the cold boot
emulator for now
and move on to the
next part of the demo.
So in addition to Quick
Boot, in July of 2018,
we've extended the snapshots
feature to be more general.
So with Quick Boot you can only
have one snapshot being saved
and loaded at any one time.
And that can be useful,
but maybe sometimes you
want to test different
device configurations,
different device
states and so forth.
And before now, we didn't really
have a good way to do that.
But in the latest emulator
stable version, 27.3.10,
which was released
July 2018, we're
now giving you the
generic snapshot's UI.
In this generic snapshot's UI
you can save and load snapshots
arbitrarily.
So for example,
I can immediately
resume one of these snapshots
to stopwatch running.
And a stopwatch is running.
I can also edit each one of
these snapshots and add notes.
And the description is saved
and is also displayed over here.
I can also take new snapshots
with the Take Snapshot button.
So these are some
examples of what
we have been doing
with snapshots,
and trying to make your life
easier when you're deploying
apps and testing them.
I would also like
to at this point
go over some
improvements we made
to the Quick Boot
mechanism itself
in recent emulator canaries.
The version of the emulator
running right now is 28015.
In a recent emulator
canaries we've
tried to listen to your concerns
about extremely long saving
time for the emulator
when you're closing it.
Now if you want to
save the emulator--
actually, wait.
Let's just set up
the stopwatch again.
It's saved.
Trust me.
It is.
Yes, it was saved.
So we've employed
new technologies
like file backing of
the guest RAM in order
to speed this process up.
In addition, we've also
added some console commands
that are useful for CI
users when using snapshots.
One very common workflow
is to reset the device
to a particular previous
state and then run your test
and then reset the
device state again.
To that end, we've added
this command called--
in the console it's called
AVD Snapshot Remap zero.
So assuming you're using
the default settings,
it's like you're auto-saving
the current device
state all the time.
So right now we're
on the second--
we're at 40 seconds.
So the first time you run this
it'll save it around then.
But the next time you run it, it
will very quickly rewind there.
So this happens quite
quickly, because all
the rest of the
emulator UI and all
that has already been
set up, it's just
a device state that's changing.
So we can just keep doing this,
like rewinding very quickly.
And you can be in any
state of the device.
And just keep going back
through that one state
very quickly with this command.
Another feature that we've been
working on in recent emulator
canaries is launching multiple
instances of the same AVD.
So let me just
set this up again.
Zero seconds.
All right.
So before, when you're
using the emulator,
if you want to test multiple
different device states
and launch them all at
the same time in parallel,
your options are pretty limited.
You first had to create a
whole bunch of AVDs that
reflected different
device settings
and launched them
all in parallel,
or and you couldn't even start
two instances of the same AVD
because you got this error
message saying that the AVD was
already in use.
Well, we have a new
command for that now.
It's called read only.
I will show you
the command here.
Actually, it's missing,
but I'll type it again.
So it is called -read-only.
And so when you
run this command,
the emulator will start
but discard all changes.
I am starting it
in the background
just to make it easy
to start many of them.
So I've just started
a second one.
It's actually
overlapped on the first.
A third one.
A fourth one.
And so you have these AVDs that
are all running independently,
but they're off
the same AVD name
because I just used API
28 for each of them.
And notice here I'm printing
out the FPS and memory stats.
And why are some of these only
around 200 or 300 megabytes
of resonant memory?
Well, that goes back to using a
file mapping for the guest RAM.
In this case, the parts
of the guest memory
that they share in common, that
they have not modified yet,
will be shared and
will not occupy
proportional set size
of resident memory
or what have you.
So this is called
copy and write.
And we hope that this
makes your experience
developing apps and testing
them more streamlined.
Thank you.
Now back to Yahan.
Back to the slides.
YAHAN ZHOU: That's nice.
So I think it's kind
of obvious to see,
but here is a comparison
of the boot time
if you are using the Quick
Boot feature versus if you
are doing the Cold Boot.
So and Cold Boot, it takes
you more than 20 seconds
to do the snapshot safe
on our Mapper Pro Machine
as we are demoing it today.
And on Quick Boot it is
usually about one second.
So back to the frame
for the next demo.
Yep.
Back to the demo.
FRANK YANG: So the next
part starts out with--
we've also improved the GPU
performance of the emulator
in recent versions
and in recent years.
We worked a lot to bring OpenGL
ES 2 support very conformant,
and to support OpenGL ES 3.
To this end, we've created
some benchmark demo
apps that showcase what
the emulator is capable of.
So I'm just starting
this test over here.
And so you can run pretty
like real-time 3D applications
like this that are competitive
with real device performance.
But before we go any further,
I'd like to go back to Yahan
in the slides to go over
another interesting feature.
YAHAN ZHOU: So coming back
to the Snapshot support,
if you remember in
2010, the emulator--
like even before
Emulator [INAUDIBLE],,
we have our Quick Boot
feature and Snapshot support.
And back in those
times, the emulator
only supports snapshots
for RAM, Disk, and CPU.
The big missing part here
was GPU based snapshot.
So this eventually
falls our users
to choose between a hardware
GPU emulation and the Quick Boot
feature.
If you choose the
hardware GPU emulation,
you get a pretty nice
runtime performance,
but your boot time will suffer.
And you indeed are a slow boot.
If you choose the
Quick Boot feature,
your boot time will
be fast, but you'll
have no runtime
hardware GPU support,
which means the runtime
performance will suffer.
So this is in 2010.
And people have always
chose one between the two.
And it is 2018 now.
We have better
version of everything,
including the hardware
GPU snapshot support.
This allows our users to
choose both the Quick Boot
feature as well as hardware
GPU emulation simultaneously.
So if you look at
what was happening
behind the scene for this
hardware GPU snapshot support,
here is the emulator GPU stack.
At the highest level, you've
got the emulated Android
OS, which issue GPU commands.
At the lowest level, you've got
your hardware graphics card,
which accept and
execute GPU commands.
In between them we have the
emulator layer, which we call,
then, translator.
So the translator will translate
GPU commands from the emulated
Android into your hardware GPU.
When we are doing the
GPU snapshot support,
we put all our snapshot logic
into the translator layer,
such that if you
serialize its own space
and dump them into your
snapshot saved file.
So one big question here
was the hardware state,
which is eventually [INAUDIBLE]
through the emulator
and different renders
implemented differently.
So to save and load
hardware states,
we use standard GL [? APIs ?]
to fetch all the hardware states
from your hardware-- what is
calleed into the translator
layer.
Then the translator layer
will serialize all of them
and write them into
your snapshot file.
In this way we can save and
recover your whole emulated
hardware GPU states.
Frank, you want to talk about--
FRANK YANG: All right.
Thank you, Yahan.
Now, in this demo, I'd
like to demonstrate
that the GPU state is being
snapshotted in its entirety.
We didn't just do something
special case for Android UI.
It can resume 3D apps like
this almost immediately
with the Snapshot Load feature.
All right.
And you can-- for those of you
who don't know already, you
can rotate the
emulator orientation
using these rotate buttons.
So back to the slides.
I'd like to show a
brief presentation.
All right.
So I know that many of
you know this already,
but for the benefit of
people in the audience who
don't know yet, I would like to
recap on some of the basic ways
to use the command line to
launch the emulator, which
can include some useful
options if you're running a CI
server or otherwise power user.
So the emulator resides in
your Android SDK folder,
Android SDK root slash emulator.
And once you're
in that directory,
you have to give the AVD name
using the dash AVD command line
option.
Note that this name
may differ from what's
displayed in the AVD manager.
So if you want to know what the
exact sequence of characters
that you need to
input there, then you
run emulator dash list AVDs.
Second, how do you
control Quick Boot?
Sometimes you don't
want to use snapshots
or you don't want to save
your changes on exit.
Well, we've got you covered.
So the first one,
No Snapshot Load
is to perform a cold
boot without attempting
to load the current state
that is on the device.
The second one, Quick Boot
discard changes to snapshot,
is good for some CI use
cases and for people
who just want the consistent
startup experience
and want to wipe it clean
when they're done with it.
In this you entered No Snapshot
Save on the command line.
And all of the changes
to the snapshot
will be discarded when
you exit the emulator.
Finally, if snapshots
are just not your thing,
you can add No Snapshot
to the command line,
and that will bring the emulator
back to the way it was before.
And to recap, in the
demo I gave earlier,
when I was launching multiple
instances of the same AVD,
well, that is the
read only option.
That option will
control whether you're
allowed to run multiple
instances of the same AVD
or not.
And when you're running in
that mode, all of the changes
to both the guest virtual disk
and to the snapshot, whatever
you do, it'll be
discarded when you exit.
To invoke this you would
run emulator dash AVD,
the AVD name, followed
by dash read dash only.
And I put an
ampersand at the end--
you don't have to-- to
launch it in background.
It's just convenient
for demo purposes here.
All right.
Now I'd like to
also talk about some
of the command line options
for some of the features
that we have introduced
recently to the emulator.
In particular, screen record.
Screen record is a
feature where you
can record the contents of
the emulator to a video file
and then play them back
using your favorite app.
This is great for
CI users who want
to be able to easily record
what's going on when running
tests on their app, and to
easily send reproductions
of bugs to stakeholders.
So the first set of commands
concerns how to start and stop
the screen recording.
ADB emu screenrecord
start, followed by the path
to the file, will
start the recording.
And it is important that you
provide the absolute path.
Otherwise, you might
not get it saved.
It's a little confusing.
Sorry.
We're working on it.
The second command, ADB
emu screenrecord stop,
stops the recording, and is
a signal to save the file.
So after you're done with
that, you can access the file.
The second one concerns
if you don't really
want the full video
recording part,
you can instead just
take a screenshot.
In this use case,
the console command
is screenrecord screenshot
followed by path
to the directory where you want
the screenshots to be saved.
Now, let's go to the demo, where
I will demonstrate the screen
recording commands.
So we're on the
emulator right now.
And let's try to find a
different app to record.
Why don't we start
up the camera?
All right.
So we're here.
So that's going on.
And I'm going to run this.
So AB emu AVD screenrecord
start users [INAUDIBLE],,
it's my username, documents,
Dev Summit, demo.webm.
So while it's recording,
let's just move around in here
a little bit to make something
happen and stop the recording.
OK, that's weird, kind of.
Oh, sorry, I accidentally
typed AVD there.
Yeah, so let's do
another recording.
All right, so the
video is saved.
And you can open it in
your favorite web browser.
OK.
Let's see.
Yeah.
There we go.
So it's a webm file.
It will work in
most major browsers.
Second, there is also a UI
for recording these screens.
It is in the extended controls
under the Screen Record tab.
So in the Screen Record
tab, it starts out
with a single button,
Start Recording.
So once we're starting recording
I'll move around a little bit.
Maybe go to recents, swipe
away those apps, and stop.
Now, once you're
done recording, you
don't have to save it to a file.
You can preview it directly
in the extended controls UI.
So this is just a video
of what we just did.
Go to recents, swipe away
the apps, go back to it
on the screen.
But you can still save
it in wherever you want.
So let's just save
this as demo two.
And that similarly
works in the browser.
OK.
So that's one of the
features that we've
added in 2017 and 2018,
is screen recording,
to make your CI
use cases better.
Another feature that we've
been doing a lot of work on,
and is pretty exciting,
is AR core support.
Now, AR core support consists
of a few main components.
The first one, which you
may have seen already,
is the virtual scene camera.
With the virtual scene camera
we render a virtual environment,
which is suitable to image
recognition and model
placement in AR apps.
So I will demonstrate
a few of them here.
In the background,
in Android Studio,
I've opened the augmented
image AR core sample.
This is available in Sceneform
Android SDK from GitHub.
And what AR core
provides in it--
it's not just for the emulator,
but there is also integrations
in studio as well.
So for example, there
is this Sceneform plugin
for Android Studio where
we can view models that are
meant for use in AR core apps.
In addition, we can change
all the material properties
we want directly in studio.
So this is the lower left frame.
And I might just say
lower the red tint a bit.
OK, I guess that didn't really
change the color very much.
So I'm going to change
blue to zero as well.
So once you save these files,
the models should get reloaded,
and you'll see that it's
mostly pure green now.
And we can-- the workflow,
we can just edit this model
and deploy it to the
device while we wait--
I guess.
Right.
And so in this app, we
are looking for images
to recognize.
Another feature that we've added
to the emulator for AR core
support is the ability
to load augmented images.
This is in the extended controls
panel under the Camera tab.
Now we can choose
different posters
to appear inside
the virtual scene.
And I've set this
JPEG of the Earth
to appear both on the
table and the wall.
So once you travel inside
the scene with this,
and turn, face the wall, we're
starting to detect the image.
And it shows up there.
So this shows that we can--
if you're a
developer of AR apps,
you have this
end-to-end workflow
where we can start
in Studio and do it
all in the emulator with
the virtual scene camera.
So that's pretty cool.
Finally, another feature
that I would like to mention,
I'd like to call out-- unless,
if you haven't seen it before,
is improved support for updating
GMS core and Google Play
services.
This is very important
to app developers
because they need to test
how the app will actually
run with different
versions of GMS core.
If you are using a Google Play
Store image, in the extended
controls panel there is
a tab called Google Play,
and inside it there
is this button
that shows, both your current
GMS core version and a button
to update it.
Once you press Update, you'll
be taken to the Play Store
and be given the
option to update it.
I happen to have
updated already.
And this is the latest
version, so it does not give me
a prompt to update here.
But if a new version does
come out, it would say Update.
I would also like to talk about
the integration of the Play
Store and the
emulator in general.
So this can be useful
for app developers who
would like to test their app
in more end-to-end scenarios.
For example, if
your app requires
other apps to be installed
in order to work,
you can download them from
the Play Store directly.
Also, you can look at your
app in the marketplace
and see how users are
reacting to it right
there, and from different
device sizes and form factors.
And so that concludes
the feature demos.
So back to Yahan and the slides.
YAHAN ZHOU: All right.
So here you saw a summary of the
features we talk about today.
If you might have noticed,
there are two channels
of the emulator out there.
So the first one is the
stable channel, which
is the one you normally get.
The latest update
was from July, 2018.
And the second channel
is the canary channel,
which is less stable, but it has
all the cutting-edge features
we have in the emulator.
And it is released weekly.
So feel free to try it out.
And in the stable
channel, we have
this list of features
already released, including
more Hypervisor supports, Quick
Boot feature, Generic Snapshot
feature, the Play Stores,
and screen recording,
and the AR Core and
Virtual Sensor supports.
If you are trying out the
canary channel emulator,
you have a few more stuff,
including the faster Quick
Boot, feature as we have
shown in today's demo.
As far as the multi
instance support.
And for those of you who
are curious about how
to switch the channel,
here is a instruction.
In the Android Studio you can
turn on your preference page,
and in the updates you have
your channel switch right there.
After that you go to the
emulator download page
and you will see the
newer version of it
available for download.
So I believe that
concludes our talk.
So we'll be QA'ing
in the [? laundry. ?]
So thanks for attending.
FRANK YANG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]